NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I'm Natalie Villalobos,
and I have the extreme honor
of leading the Women Techmakers
program here at Google.
I love that she shared that
story about Megan, because I
remember when Megan had
said, oh, yeah, yeah.
That job you interviewed
for-- you came in second.
And I'm like, that's
not the same as first.
But when her and I were creating
this opportunity of Women
Techmakers, she was
such an incredible woman
in saying yes to me.
And when you're
taking on a big idea--
when you're taking
on a project--
you really need people to get
behind you to make it happen.
And Megan was one of
those people for me
and I'm forever supportive
and grateful for her guidance.
And a lot of times, I feel like
Women Techmakers is actually
my startup within Google.
It's about creating an
opportunity for other people
to thrive with something--
even though it's not a product,
it's really an organization
and an opportunity
for people around the world.
We have an incredible team.
I still have to go
raise money and have
a budget like everybody
else and have metrics
like everybody else,
and so I'm going
to hold that as my startup.
It's not like any
of the startups
that these women have created.
They have different obstacles.
And so we want to explore
some of those obstacles,
but also some of those meaty
nuggets of knowledge in case
you want to start your own
initiative or something
within your company, or maybe
even start your own company.
I have a handy dandy-- let's
see if they're in here.
It's like a magic show.
All right.
A couple questions.
I haven't introduced any
of y'all because I think
it's actually more powerful
when women introduce themselves.
Will you tell me your
name and your company
and what you're solving for?
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Sure.
Well, my name is
Susan Gregg Koger.
I am the chief creative officer
and co-founder of ModCloth.
We inspire personal
style and help
our customers feel like the
best versions of themselves.
And we do that by
designing clothing,
like the dress that
I'm wearing today,
working with
independent designers
to carry their products,
like the beautiful jumpsuit--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I also
happen to be wearing ModCloth.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER:
Thank you for that.
I appreciate that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: No problem.
She did not pay me
for that, by the way.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: I offered to.
But you're supporting my
business, which I love.
And yeah, that's about--
and I actually-- I
started ModCloth when I was 17.
So ModCloth is
basically my career.
So I have a unique perspective.
I've been doing it for
14 years this summer.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
Melissa?
MELISSA WONG: Great.
Hi.
I'm Melissa, the CEO and
co-founder of Retail Zipline.
And different than Susan--
my background, actually,
was 10 years working
at Gap, Inc.,
always focused on solving the
store execution problem, which
is how do you get stores to do
the work that headquarters is
asking them to do when you
have thousands of locations
and tens of thousands
of employees?
And so I started
a Retail Zipline
to help retailers also achieve
the best version of themselves,
but in their store environments
and with their store teams.
I've been doing this
for about a year.
And it was a very big jump
going from enterprise,
like a large Fortune
500 retailer,
into a very small startup.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Beautiful.
And Bri?
BRI JAMES: Hey, all.
My name is Bri James, and
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of Scrumpt.
We're a lunch kit
subscription service for kids.
And my pediatrician
mom is my co-founder,
which is fun and awesome.
And we're on a mission
to make lunches for kids
awesome and super easy.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Great.
That opportunity that I was
talking to you about when
Melody all of a
sudden appears-- now
is going to be the time when
we greet her to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Hi, thanks.
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's OK.
We're going to edit that out.
I actually was scared I was
going to slip out on my heels,
so you did it for me.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Excuse me.
I mean shoot, goodness.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Stuff and things.
Fun fact before Melody
introduces herself
and her company and
what you're solving for,
I have actually known
Melody for many years.
We actually went to
high school together.
So it's a privilege
for me to be able to--
as with a lot of
the work that I do--
shine a spotlight
on incredible women,
even if I happen to have
known them for half my life.
Melody, will you tell
us about StyleSeat
and what you're solving for?
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Absolutely.
In addition to being late,
my name is Melody McCloskey.
My company is StyleSeat, which
is like Open Table for hair
salons and spas.
In addition to the fact that
we help women look and feel
good and try to make it
as easy easy as possible,
we're also an amazing platform
for female entrepreneurs.
75% of the business owners that
run their business on StyleSeat
and double their revenue
in the first yeay-- they're
female business owners.
So we help women
in the beauty space
run their businesses
more effectively,
better support their families,
and be more successful.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
And we'll get into a
little bit of creating
a mission-driven company.
Let's actually go to that.
Why did you start StyleSeat?
What was the opportunity
that you saw?
Because really, the theme of
this panel is building an idea.
So what was the idea
that you had and you're
like-- got the crazy feeling
of, this needs to be a company.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Yeah.
I'll tell you, I didn't know
that much about the beauty
industry before I started.
I had been in tech.
I had worked in
product for a while.
But I looked around the room,
or the scene of Silicon Valley
back in 2010, 2011,
and I personally
didn't know a single
female founder.
I knew tons of guys-- dozens--
I mean hundreds of guys--
that had started companies.
And I know that there were
female founders at the time.
I just didn't know
any personally.
And so I knew that I
wanted to start a company
and I was surrounded by
really supportive friends.
But I thought, OK,
let me start a company
in a female-driven sector
because I think I'll
have a competitive advantage.
And beauty is a
massive industry.
So that's how I started into it.
And I think what's been so
surprising is, after we started
to get big and we
built a product
that there was a lot of
need for and our customers
started to freak out and
love it, it went from,
I'm starting this because it's
a big financial opportunity,
I want to build a big business.
And turned into me
having conversations
with these women
who are saying, I've
been in the beauty
industry for 10 years,
but I've always had
to have a second job
because I'm too scared
to really make the leap.
I have to be a
paralegal's assistant
or I have to work second
hours at this other company
because I'm too scared to
have my family be fully
dependent on this
because my business isn't
as effective as it could be.
And now, with StyleSeat,
it is and I've
been doing this full time
and I'm making more revenue
than I ever have.
And all of a sudden, it was
like, wow, this surprised me.
And now it's this
really meaningful thing
for our customers.
And now that is definitely
the core driver of who we are.
And it's so much
more interesting
and profound than the
money opportunity.
And that's what drives
everyone at the company today.
They don't care as much about
the revenue opportunity.
It's really about
helping people.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Bri, how about you?
BRI JAMES: I was a
lawyer once upon a time
and had a buddy who was starting
a company who gave me a job.
And it was awesome.
It got acquired and
I had another buddy
who started another company
and the opposite happened.
It folded like that.
But I had seen both ends
of the startup spectrum
and knew I wanted
to start something.
What that was was still
a big question mark.
But my mom was retiring.
We had always talked about
starting something together.
And she says, if you want me
on board, it has to be healthy
and it has to be for kids.
And I was like OK, noted.
And I knew I wanted to do
something in the product space.
I don't have a tech background,
so building something quickly
that we can move to the
market was important.
So we just boiled all
of our passions together
and then that's how
Scrumpt came to be.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Beautiful.
Melissa?
MELISSA WONG: Great.
I actually never thought that
I would be an entrepreneur.
I didn't think I
was in my blood.
I never dreamed of it
when I was a child.
Even probably three years ago,
I never really thought about it.
But the way that
Retail Zipline came
is I kept on facing the
same problem within the Gap
about store execution.
Started talking to a lot of
other people in the industry.
Everyone had the same problem.
So why we exist is really
to solve the problem
that retailers face
across the board.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER:
I started ModCloth
in the summer between
high school and college.
And it really was a fun project.
I grew up in South
Florida and actually, I
started-- my co-founder
is my husband today, who
was my boyfriend at the time.
I married the guy that
I went to prom with,
which is a whole other story.
You can find me later and
we can talk about that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's a different panel.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah,
that's a different panel.
Yeah.
He's wonderful and
amazing-- Eric.
Yeah.
He had two friends in high
school that got together
and they started a web hosting,
web development business.
Basically, going to small
businesses in South Florida
and telling them,
hey, it's 2001.
Let's get on the internet.
I'll help you build a website.
So he had built a
few e-commerce sites
and had designed a
few different sites.
And I just always loved fashion.
I always had an eye for it.
I remember being
very young and having
a very strong opinion of this
pair of shoes versus that one.
I was always just-- I remembered
every single piece of clothing
I ever saw.
It took me years and years to
realize that that was actually
a skill and wasn't
just something
that everyone could do.
I'd be like, you don't
remember that thing
that you wore yesterday
and when you bought it
and how much it was and what
other colors it came in?
Turns out, that's really
good stuff that's not normal.
It took me a while
to figure that out.
So yeah, long story
short, I had to shop
for a whole new wardrobe because
I got into Carnegie Mellon
University in Pittsburgh.
Those of you who grew
up in warm climates
and then had to move to a cold
climate for the first time
like I did-- you have to
buy coats and scarves.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Thicker things.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
And I went to thrift
stores because I
didn't have a lot of money.
I found amazing vintage.
And Eric actually the one
that suggested, why don't you
try to sell some of this stuff?
And eBay wasn't so
exciting for me,
but the idea of building a
website seemed kind of cool.
So I taught myself
Photoshop and I
think I used Microsoft
FrontPage to design
the first version of the site.
We just hacked it onto an
open source shopping cart
and it was nuts.
But it was really fun.
And as I kept-- as I
was an undergraduate,
I was a business and
German double major.
Honestly because I didn't
even know that you could
work in the fashion industry.
I just thought you
can be a designer
or you can-- I don't
know, work at a store.
And I was like, I
don't know that I
want to do either
of those things
and I'm not sure that
I can really draw.
So I had no idea
that what I was doing
was going to be able
to turn into something
that I could actually grow.
But I was at school between 2002
and 2006 and Facebook launched.
The world was changing
and my business
started to really gain traction.
And honestly, for
me, it's always
been-- my job's gone from
doing everything to now,
today, I get to-- I've been
able to create my dream job.
And when I say that, I mean
29 days out of the month,
it's like, this is my dream job.
And then I have the one day
where I'm like, oh, my god,
who put me in charge?
This is insane and I just
want to get back into bed
and pull the covers up.
But I think everyone goes
through that, no matter
where they are and
whether they're
running a tiny startup
in a big company
or running their own thing, or
just trying to proceed in life.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: We
all have our bad days.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
But at least, I think,
in wearing ModCloth, I would
look good having a bad day.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: That's true.
I would hope so.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Bri, you
had mentioned that your mom is
your co-founder.
BRI JAMES: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Will you talk to us
a little bit about what
life is like having
your mom as your co-founder?
BRI JAMES: Sure.
It's difficult
because you always
have a mother-daughter dynamic.
Sometimes she's just
going to say no,
and eventually,
you're going to win.
But you just have
to let her think
that she's winning for a while.
But no, in all
honesty, it's great.
And I think people are
very taken aback by that--
that we've done this now
for two years together
and it hasn't come to blows.
But no one wants to see you
succeed more than your parents.
And there's no one who
you want to make prouder
than your parents.
So I think there's definitely
a very powerful energy there.
And if you have that
relationship with your mother
or your father or
someone in your family
and you can make it
work, then I think
it's a really powerful
and beautiful thing.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
A few of you had
touched on-- you mentioned that
you were a lawyer before, you
said you were kind
of naturally attuned
to the world of curating--
you had a curatorial eye.
When you jumped into taking an
idea and building a company,
did you have to have a
bunch of things in place
before you made the leap?
Or did you make the leap and
then everything came to you?
How did that work?
MELISSA WONG: I
guess-- are you--
I'll actually-- I'll address
that because I think,
a lot of times,
one of the things
that had frustrated me
earlier when I was at Gap
is everyone talks about
doing something different.
And waking up in the middle of
the night and kind of pivoting
and knowing what
you're supposed to do.
And I think, for me, it was
such a gradual process of,
I have an idea.
I think I can do it.
No, I don't think I can do it.
And then I'll find out more
information and I'm like,
yes, I can do it.
And then it's like,
no, I can't do it.
And I find out more information,
and I'm like, actually, I can.
So it's just a very
gradual, incremental process
of learning what I
needed as I went.
Just taking one step at a time.
Finding the confidence
to take the next step.
And then, eventually,
you get to the point
where you're like, I've
done all of the things
that I never thought were
possible when I look back.
And I think this
is the time for me
to actually take
the biggest step
and to take the biggest risk.
But I've done a
lot of my homework
and I've found like
my footing and now I
can actually move forward.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Any--
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: I
feel really similar.
I think the biggest
struggle and battles
you have, especially in
the first year or two
of the business--
and maybe the year
leading up to the
business-- is just
having the confidence to do it.
I thought about
StyleSeat for two years
before I started the company.
And there was always--
I just never believed
that I could do it.
It was like, everyone I know
is so much smarter than me.
All these guys are engineers
and I'm not, so I can't do it.
Or they're more
analytical than me,
and it's just not my skill set.
I should just pack
up and go home.
And then, finally,
I woke up one day
and I was like, if someone else
starts this company that's not
me, I'm going to lose my shit.
I'm going to freak out and I'm
going to regret that really,
really, really deeply.
That will be the biggest
regret of my life.
Trying it and falling
on my face and failing
in front of everyone
is less-- that's
not as bad as not doing it
and having someone else do it.
And now, I feel like through
the state of the business,
it continues to
be that way, where
OK, now we have to
raise a Series A.
I don't know if I can do this.
This seems impossible.
And then you do it.
Or we have to go recruit
a really big executive
or we have to go sign a massive
deal with a big company.
And then a bunch
of those happen,
and then you get to this
point where you're like,
anything that gets thrown
at me-- I know that I
can try my best to get it done.
And I'm not fearful
of it anymore.
And that's been the
biggest transformation,
I think, for me.
That's been like the biggest
gift of running a company.
I know now-- no
matter what happens,
it can't get as dark as
it did in the beginning
stages of starting the company.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Totally.
And something you
said-- I think you
said you were scared of
going out there and falling
flat on your face.
And one of the biggest
learnings for me has been--
even when you're--
this is cliche,
but there are no
overnight success stories.
You will fall flat on your
face, even as you succeed.
Part of succeeding is failing.
And we talk about this in
building technology quickly.
This is a general
life lesson that
is easy to understand
intellectually,
I've found, but is hard to
internalize and actually
put into practice.
I don't know.
I think five years
ago in my career,
I would look at those dudes who
have very successful companies.
Let's just say-- am I allowed
to say Zuckerberg here?
OK.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's
not a bad word here.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: He's
the same age as me.
He was the same year at school.
So I'm like, oh,
man, I'm not him.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: You're not
a billionaire by 23 or whatever.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: But
I'm doing pretty good.
So you do always look
around and you're like,
oh, man, I'm not doing
it right because I'm not
this successful.
But then, as it starts to happen
to you, you're like, oh, right,
it is running and falling
and running and falling.
And sometimes you
just say, OK, I'm
not going to be on
this track anymore.
I'm going do something else.
And that is life, in business--
professionally, personally,
all of that.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: And there's
been a lot of times in my life
where maybe a company
came out after us.
And they had this big press
story or this big, seemingly
public success.
And I would beat
myself up and say,
they raised their round faster,
they got to traction faster.
What could I have-- and I'd
really just beat myself up.
And then that company wouldn't
be around a year later.
And that happened
a bunch of times.
And I guess the point is
you can't compare yourself
to others because you have
no idea what's happening
underneath the scenes.
You can just concentrate on
yourself and run forward.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
One of the things
that came up when we were having
our prep panel conversation is,
I was sharing a life lesson
that I try to live by,
but is also difficult,
which is I am not my work.
My work is something I do.
And that's really hard
when you have this passion
and you need to be birth
this company into the world.
Are you able to-- and it sounds
like it might be a little bit
difficult-- to detach your
self-worth from your company?
So that if it's having
a hard day, you can say,
hard day, we're
putting that over here.
I'm actually going
to go to Pilates
and I'm going to rock
the crap out of Pilates.
I'm going to be good.
And you take care of yourself.
How do you-- can
you do that when
you're running a company
where all bets are off
and you are having to
meet investor need?
MELISSA WONG: I was actually
thinking about that a lot
because it's like, you're
so passionate about what
you're doing.
How do you not get
so consumed by it
and then just get
dragged down when
the going gets really tough?
And I think it's really
important to maintain
those other sides of yourself.
Yes, I'm a founder.
Yes, I'm an innovator,
I'm a creator.
But then, I'm also a traveler.
I'm also a cook.
I'm a reader.
I think it's the balance.
You can't ever detach
yourself from the company
that you've created
and what you've built,
but you can balance it
out by identifying deeply
with those other
sides of yourself
so you don't just get so
consumed by one thing.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: I
was incapable of it.
I think it took me like
four, four and a half years
to finally have an identity for
myself outside of the business.
Even taking time to
work out, for example.
Now, I wake up at 5:45, I
go to the gym immediately,
I work out pretty intensely.
And I don't do that-- it
took me a while to say,
I'm going to sleep early.
I'm not going to--
I'm only going
to do two work dinners
a week because I need
to go to sleep early
so I can wake up
and I can do this
and be a sane person.
But I'm a better founder
because I do those things.
And I want my team to do
those things for themselves.
So I'm setting a bad example
if I don't take care of myself.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: One
of my favorite things
that you do to take
care of yourself is--
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
This is something that,
similarly, took me a really
long time to figure out.
Because I think when
you're a founder--
or when you do
anything that you're
passionate about, whether you're
starting it yourself or not,
you feel like, oh,
well, I will work harder
and then it will be better.
And so you don't allow yourself
to take that time to recharge.
When actually, what you
need to do is recharge
and then you can
actually work harder.
You can't just keep going.
And I think,
particularly when you're
younger-- earlier
in your career--
you feel like, I can just
do it, I can just do it.
And so the whole work smart,
not hard thing, I think,
is really applicable.
And you have to take
care of yourself
so that you're a better team
member, you're a better boss,
you're a better family member.
You can be more present.
Yeah.
And one of the things that I
do that I started in the last--
probably two years now is
I'm a-- I've discovered
this passion for aerial arts.
So I do flying trapeze
and trampoline.
That's why I have all these
terrific bruises right now.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's
because you flung yourself.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
And it's the most
incredible thing
and it's not for everyone.
Come talk to me about it
after if you are interested.
We can go together.
It's not for everyone.
But I do encourage
everyone to find something
like that that does--
if I'm at the office
and I have a 6 o'clock
class, I leave.
I go.
I fly for an hour.
It's extremely aerobic and it's
challenging and it's scary,
but I do it anyway.
And then, I'm like, OK, I
couldn't think about anything
else during that hour.
And now I'm ready to go back.
I can choose to go back
to work if I want to.
If my body is telling
me you shouldn't go back
to work yet-- you're
still stressed out
even after doing all that
stuff-- I can call a friend
or do something that
will help me get there.
Or just go to bed early.
Sleep is so important.
So, so, so important.
BRI JAMES: And I think
one of the reasons
that we forsake self
care is because it
seems really aggressive.
It seems like something that's
going to take a lot of time
that we have to do so
persistently and diligently,
which we definitely should.
But sometimes it just
takes the little things.
Sometimes I'll feel
like garbage and I say,
I have not had any water today.
Just drink a glass of water.
Go for a walk.
Get up and stretch.
I bought this thing
called a sun lamp,
and if you live in the Bay where
it's always dark and gloomy,
it's awesome.
It emanates the sun in
your office or your house.
And my co-workers will
come in and be like, it's
like the beach in here.
And I'm like, yeah, exactly.
And it's awesome.
So there's a lot of little
things for self care,
I think, that we
can do, too, that
makes it seem less overwhelming
and maybe we can ascribe to--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
I was actually so bad
at drinking water.
There's actually
an app for that.
You can look it up in
the Google Play Store.
I think it's like,
Drinkwater or something.
And so every hour,
there's a sound
that goes off on my phone.
What freaks people
out is that it
sounds like a toilet flushing.
So maybe don't have
it up as high as I do,
but I then describe to
people how important it
is for me to be drinking water.
And so the water bottles that
you have at your tables--
definitely fill those
up with water or coffee
or whatever--
actually, I don't know.
It might burn you.
But double check, mates.
But having water is actually
just this basic need
that you can do to
take care of yourself.
Because when you get super
stressed out and you're in it,
you literally forget to
take care of yourself.
So I'm so thankful that you
shared a lot of these tips.
OK.
You went to trapeze,
you feel super strong,
you're feeling good.
You did the self care.
You meditate a little bit.
Now you're stepping
into your company
and you have the
next big project
you need someone to ship or
your team to follow your vision.
How do you convince a team of
people to follow you that way?
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: I think,
for me-- my personal style--
and I'm still-- I think one
of the most interesting things
about running a company is that
you get leadership training.
You're just thrown
into figuring out how
to be a leader and a manager.
For me, it's about working hard
and just being very honest,
even when it feels
very uncomfortable.
Because for me, it is-- I
do feel kind of awkward.
I'm not like, I can't wait
to get in front of 30 people
and talk to them.
You guys are really lovely.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: With
your Superwoman pose.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
I do that.
At my company and doing
external stuff like this.
But I care so much
about it and I
care about-- I've seen
women that have inspired me,
so I come and I get over
my fear and I do this
because I want to
help other people.
Similarly, for me to rally
the troops, rally the team,
it's just expressing how
passionate I am about it
and just putting that out
there and being vulnerable.
Being vulnerable and like,
oh, my god, you guys,
I'm so excited about this.
This is amazing.
Even if I sound really
dumb and I just said oh,
my god four times, that--
if you're at ModCloth,
that is something--
that's why you're there.
Because you saw
me at some point.
Or you saw people that
I've hired that have
brought that same energy.
So for me, it's really just
being vulnerable and putting it
out there and looking
around and making sure
that others are coming with me.
BRI JAMES: I think,
in the beginning,
most people are excited.
I think the hard part comes
when you're six weeks in
and you're shipping
in eight weeks
and it seems like it's
not going to happen.
And everyone's
kind of panicking.
And so we try to celebrate
the little wins along the way,
because it's those
nuggets that-- when
you're in that panic--
carry you through.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Absolutely.
BRI JAMES: A fun
thing that we do
is-- every sort of piece of
positive customer feedback,
we put in this giant mason jar
that we call a gratitude jar.
And so when you're
feeling horrible,
you can read something
sweet that a customer says.
And it gives you just
a little pick-me-up
to get through the next
step and make sure that you
make those ship deadlines.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: I
think being really
data-driven and transparent
is where we come from.
So if people are like, why
did we make this decision?
Well, we made this
decision because-- let
me give you what the options
were, let me tell you
the data behind it.
I know that that might not
be something that you wanted,
but this is why
we did it and this
is why it's in the greater
good of the company.
I think that goes a long way,
especially with engineers.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yes.
You've got to know how to
sell to the right audience.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Yeah, exactly.
MELISSA WONG: I just think
clear-- what I'm hearing
and what I experience--
just clear communication.
Knowing what your intent
is and just being authentic
and just being yourself.
Like, hey, I'm scared
about this also.
I'm also nervous
about running behind.
But it's so important to the
success of our customers.
It's like, you're not-- you're
meeting people where they're at
and sharing your own experience.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
We're getting
to the very end of our
panel-- and honestly, I
can hang out with all
these ladies up here,
but I know that they also
want to meet you at lunch.
Last question.
If you could have
a mantra or a quote
or a song lyric that
takes you through the day
or accurately describes what
it's like to be a founder,
what would you
say that would be?
Something inspirational or
something that's like this
is really founder life.
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: OK.
My song lyric that
I always-- yeah.
"Mo money, mo problems."
You always think, more money.
And then everything-- especially
when you're starting out,
it's like oh, my god, if only
I can get to this fundraising.
And then you do it
and then you're like,
hold on, but now I have all
this other stuff I got to do.
I say it-- money is great.
But "mo money, mo problems"--
I just always remind myself.
MELISSA WONG: I think mine
comes from a teenage song,
but it goes back to regret.
It's like you only regret
the things that you don't do.
And then, I think
she's like, let's do
what we want to do now.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Do
you know who sang it?
MELISSA WONG: I think it's
this artist called Melanie C.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
From the Spice Girls?
MELODY MCCLOSKEY:
The Spice Girl?
SUSAN GREGG KOGER: Yeah.
The solo work.
I love that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's awesome.
MELISSA WONG: And then
she's like, don't give me--
don't let me have
more time to back out.
So that's why I'm always
like, push myself forward.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm a
bigger-- I was a Posh Spice.
But I think I'm now
a Mel C advocate.
I love it.
Bri?
BRI JAMES: We got to do karaoke.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Again,
that's another panel.
BRI JAMES: Yeah, singing
Spice Girls jams.
There's a Goapele
song called "Closer."
And there's a line that
says, "close your eyes
and see what you believe."
And that's really powerful
to me because I've always
been a doer, not a dreamer.
But as a startup
founder, my journey
has been learning
how to think big
and putting those things
together, which has been--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I sing
that song out loud a lot.
Every time it comes on
the radio, it's like--
BRI JAMES: Yeah, that's my jam.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: --soulful.
Melody?
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Mine's
a little less soulful.
It's "All I Do is
Win" by DJ Khaled.
But I think it's
not-- the point of it
is that I think one
of the biggest reasons
that we're still
here-- I think about me
and my co-founder--
is resiliency.
No matter how hard it gets,
it's going to get harder,
it's still going to be hard.
When you think that
you can't move forward,
you've just got to do it.
You have to win because
there's everything at stake.
And so listening to that
just reminds you, all right.
We've got to-- we
don't have a choice.
We have to do it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And if someone
wants to make a playlist
and share that out,
that would be helpful.
That's all the time we have.
I know-- like I
said, I would want
to hangout with these
ladies all day long,
but we've got
other things to do.
We've got other women
for you to meet.
So can we have a round of
applause for our panel?
[APPLAUSE]